let's talk about what's going on in new
york city new york city passes green gas
ban experts warn could lead to
electrical blackouts and soaring bills
de blasio backed law will outlaw gas
stoves and heaters in all new building
properties so that is january 2024 all
new buildings and taller ones what is it
shorter buildings of seven stories have
to go electric by january 2024 you know
new york city is it's like it's going to
be have you seen an escape from new york
yeah that's what it's going to be like
and and that's a i love that movie it's
hilarious when he like he crashed have
you seen you've seen it right ian yeah
yeah a month a couple of months ago he
put him on lighter stairs yeah he lands
on the rooftop russell going down the
building everything's he has a hot old
guy list
everything's destroyed bill de blasio
said he wants to buy up these buildings
that are you know collapsing in value
and becoming vacant to use his public
housing oh i i gotta say it looks like
everything he's doing it has the
rebuilding the projects and segregating
people that would build a block drawing
property value forcing people to flee
because he's conquering the city
now banning banning gas in buildings
well there you go i mean it's look their
vision of a future someone someone had a
really really great tweet they said
the elites they were referring to space
travel but i think it applies to all of
them they were like the the elites do
not want star trek
they do not want a star trek future they
want a feature more like dune
they want classist elitist control of
everything that they can annihilate
cooking over an open flame is probably
more than a magnitude better than
cooking on an electric wire stove where
you can't get when you have a flame you
can pick the pot up and move it around
and tilt it to get the heat exactly
right where you need it for the food ian
knows from experience the quality of
food is going to drop in new york can
you i just imagine like all the chefs in
the world that are like
you need open flames what are they going
to do um they're going to have torches
and they're gonna be holding the pan
with a torch under it they'll come up
with a really cool like hipster thing
where there's a grill in the restaurant
yeah my concern is not so much about the
quality of the food they cook but um the
blackouts the rolling blackouts
literally
yeah especially in new york remember
remember that freak ice storm that was
horrific like earlier this year that
killed people in texas partly because
they were trying to do this clean energy
move that wasn't a good thing and oh you
know the windmills froze after they
killed all the birds and used more
natural gas to make them than it
actually put outputs new york is
freaking
miserable
and and this is this is a problem do you
think that greta tunberg knows that her
plan would kill millions of people in a
matter of weeks no when she's like how
dare you
she said like we mustn't we mustn't wait
until 2030 or 2023 we must do it now
it's like if you shut off fossil fuels
right now you'd probably kill 10 million
people in a weekend exactly because all
the electricity goes out
people who who are diabetic oh they die
instantly because their insulin goes bad
and then within the matter of a couple
weeks the elderly start dying from a
lack of access to heating and cooling
yep so is you know i i have to i have to
give her the benefit out assume she just
doesn't realize she's talking about
genocide no she's being fed talking
points by the evil in my
environmentalist lobby of the world
there's another discrepancy though you
talk about how poor people
underprivileged people have been so
negatively hurt by coveting regulations
um here's something that people leftists
and radicals don't want to talk about um
is is the the poverty index when it
comes to energy
and the energy poor in the world and the
best way to raise their future their
educational their medical like their
professional economic growth is to
provide these people with the energy
that now bill de blasio and gavin newsom
are trying to take away and private
entities are the best way to do this
like if you want to have a cleaner
planet let corporations do what they do
like the private market has been so much
better for creating clean initiatives
than the government regulation or
bureaucrats or you know tax bonuses have
ever been i went to iceland a couple
years ago and it's beautiful it's
amazing
it's expensive a little bit
and what i was told by locals there was
that i was like how is it that people
live up here you know what i mean it's
like it's you know it's it's it's day
out until midnight or whatever survival
yeah there's like where do you get food
from like how do you grow food
everything smells like farts and no they
have it's true they have greenhouses
natural gas they have greenhouses for
growing vegetables and then what i was
told was before the the um advent of
geothermal
they were some of the poorest people in
the world working in like mines just
covered in filth and struggling to
survive
but once they got access to cheap clean
energy their their standard of living
skyrocketed yep now it works for them
because they live on a gigantic you know
volcanic hot spot but for people who are
in the middle of you know
america you know we got a ship in oil
and gas to them so they have the ability
they have the energy they can use for
farming equipment for homes we shouldn't
have to when we're sitting on some but i
mean i mean i mean areas that don't have
access to it right like certain not
every area has sitting on oil yeah and
so we have pipelines yep so we can ship
it to them so we can say there's a lot
here there's a little here let's move it
around and this gives people better
quality of life now i'm concerned about
you know climate change and all that
stuff too so i'd love me some fusion
there was a there's a new report i'm
really excited about they finally got
energy output from fusion you see that
ian yeah but it might have been debunked
oh really
why why you got it
i'm just a fan of like nuclear energy
yes like everybody assumes that
chernobyl is gonna happen and i'm like
guys no if you watch the hbo documentary
yeah and then you actually read a
history book you will see that like
chernobyl ain't gonna happen and even
with the uh the japanese plant that that
had all of the issues yeah what was it
fukushima fukushima yeah
okay as i
if these people though really cared
about forward movement
in the energy race to be clean then they
would be looking into nuclear infusion
and why don't they because look people
understand the problem with chernobyl
was not nuclear power it was communism
exactly a thousand percent that was like
the most conservative pro capitalistic
like american
agenda show i have ever seen come out of
bollywood when my husband i watched that
show i was like did they realize what
they were it's like squid games right
like the writer thinks that it's like a
thing about how evil capitalism is this
one really got me too because i said
that several times that squid game was
very clearly about communism yes and all
the leftists were like tim's so dumb he
doesn't understand capitalism and i said
if it was if it was an allusion to
capitalism when they did the red light
green light some people would have
started at the finish line some people
would have been in the middle and some
people had been in the back yeah when
everyone was put in a jumpsuit and put
at the beginning and told equalize run
for it yeah that's communism yeah not
capitalism yep a thousand percent i i do
kind of love it though when hollywood
assumes that there's even some some
things that they've come out with
recently that i watch it and i'm like so
i'm like this is pro-life like how did
somebody
how did somebody like i am mother did
you watch i am mother um it's a pretty
good like sci-fi movie on on netflix and
like i watched it and i'm like it's tote
i don't want to give it away but it's
like totally
love on the spectrum i totally almost
cry every episode love on the spectrum
is like about people on the spectrum
that are trying to find love and like
marriage and happiness and i'm like this
show is so pro-life because anyway have
you seen the order no so this show got
canceled there was only two seasons but
so i'll just spoil it because it's you
know i think it's it's it's this came
out like a year ago yeah the villain in
the second season this is this is like
um it's a college age show so it's
targeting people who are in there like
18 to 24. the villain in the second
season is an overt communists
it's over communists uh they go to this
guy's this professor's house and he's
got they look at his books it's like
stalin marx and the show is about a
secret society of you know mad people of
magic and that you know in order to cast
a spell you have to sacrifice something
so they cut their hands as a sacrifice
to like kessa spell and the communists
believe that there is an incantation
that will give everyone the ability to
freely use magic and the leader of the
order is like if it were true don't you
think it would have happened by now
people have tried this over and over
again you either pay now or you pay
later and i'm like man pro capitalist
netflix show
literally like it's one thing if the
villain was like
not overtly reading books on marx yeah
and they just said i believe in equality
for magic but they're literally like
their group was called praxis and
they're like marx it's good and they
were like workers unite and i'm like men
they just slapped us in the face with
this one i i off i would love to think
i'd not heard about that show but i
would love to think that somewhere in
hollywood is like a pro capitalist like
conservative that did that on purpose i
think they were experiencing flipped it
in they got cancelled though i wonder if
if at netflix they were just like look a
lot of our shows follow themes that are
more pro leftist yeah maybe if we make a
show that follows another theme we might
actually see like maybe people like the
stuff and they made the show and you
know not enough people watched it it
sounds a little too like satanic for me
i don't typically like those kinds of
shows yeah like it's it's it's not a
great show
they set the pro capitalistic message up
for failure is what you're saying
i got to be honest like
i i was eye rolling at the overt
politics that they had injected into it
and i was like and i don't want that in
my entertainment i just want to be
entertaining i wanted the werewolf to
fight the wizard yeah i mean
and like it's a brutal show because like
they show people getting their hearts
ripped out and stuff like that well most
entertainment now is propaganda and and
and it's hard not to see it everywhere
better propaganda horrible yeah
dang ali stucky the other day had a
thing where she was like posting on her
stories her insta stories all of the
things that are kind of just
like just subtly in kids shows and
there's a show that my eight-year-old
likes to watch and i walked in and i was
like what and i could show you a video i
took a video of it and i showed it to my
husband and it's like a man in a sequin
jacket with an effeminate voice and like
a ton more makeup on that i'm wearing
right now and fabulous fake eyelashes
and painted nails and i was like hey to
my eight-year-old i'm like who's this
guy she's like oh he's just on this
episode he's the bad guy and he like
wants to take over social media it was
like a very
2021 like trend right and she was like
that's the bad guy don't worry henry
danger is going to get him or whatever
the show it was and i was just like oh
my gosh it's happening or you even like
the bad guy was effeminate yeah but i'm
like well at least they they acknowledge
that you know we i i love it when
there's bad ladies on shows i'm like you
know women can be evil too like kim
jong-un's sister anyone um but so it's
it's have you seen the boys
no but i've heard it's really good the
uh and i i think it's the second season
i don't know whatever i i haven't seen
in a minute but one of the characters is
literally meant to be i'm pretty sure
like i think they were trying to rip off
laura loomer really so they got this
this she's like a nazi
like superhero or whatever
and i think it was a leftists version of
the worst like they look at laura loomer
for real watch watch it and you know
laura if you had seen this i wonder if
she's seen it because when i saw that
they announced before the season that
they were introducing an alt-right
superhero or something like this and i
roll my eyes like
you know like they're trying so hard so
original and well i remember
back
ann coulter
like i feel like there's so many
characters i think it was like ally
mcbeal svu like all these even movies
where they would show like the you know
kind of like cnn type news set that's
commenting on what's ever happening in
the movie right like i think even in day
after tomorrow there was very much
there's always like the blonde that's
making that argument and they would make
her be attractive and thin and tall like
ann coulter and it's like
it's visually that's what you know that
that's what they were thinking in the
writers room i want to make sure i make
this point clear too i am not saying
that laura's a nazi i'm saying you have
these leftists in hollywood who get this
fake media view of what laura loomer is
and then make a character based on this
fake version you know what i mean i mean
i'm surprised that they haven't done a
fake version of like rogan or shapiro or
you know what i mean it's bound to
happen probably there's a new show on
netflix called was it was it called
conspiracy theory is that it is um i
forgot the name of it oh yeah i want to
watch that i put it in my in my faves or
i don't know i don't know what i watch
the later episodes when it gets filled
with propaganda but there's there's a
one of the characters is
a
psychic mushroom from hollow earth
and he has a bit in one episode where he
can't he doesn't want to hang out with
joe rogan anymore and so like they did
dmt together or something that was
fairly neutral i thought it was funny i
i just want to be entertained yeah well
like it's like a gladiator but you gotta
understand entertainment has been
weaponized you can't relax you can't sit
back you can't enjoy a lot of content
because there's a lot of subconscious
crap that they're trying to put in your
brain because when you're watching
entertainment you let your guard down
and literally your subconscious mind
picks up all these subtle nuances all
this larger messaging all this larger
propaganda and that's why there's such
big money in the entertainment industry
and that's why there's such sinister
people like harvey weinstein like kevin
spacey within it that do absolutely
horrible things that are able to
propagandize the future of this country
and set the culture through hollywood
there's a reason a lot of people in
hollywood say that it's run by satan and
and a lot of people make jokes about it
but there's a lot of parallels there's
there's
there you are the lowest of the low if
you try to sexualize my eight-year-old
like you are the lowest of the low and
if if you are trying to and that is i
think my biggest issue with lots of
lgbtq activists that you are trying to
um change
the physical emotional hormonal and
mental out like outcome of a human being
especially before they're 18 years old
and and
using them as a political pawn for your
personal
sexual agenda it's not okay thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you